apple is officially working on a brand
new gaming device that is likely to
revolutionize ios gaming and if you
don't believe me i bet that i can prove
it to you before the end of this video
because i not only have a bunch of new
leaks to share with you but also brand
new patent filings from apple themselves
so before i get into those patents and
the new leaks i want to refresh
everyone's memory on how and when all of
these leaks originally started as well
as why right now is the perfect time for
apple's new gaming device way back in
2020 there were rumors of apple working
on a new apple tv with a stronger gaming
focus from analysts like mark german who
is extremely reliable and even the
popular leaker love to dream claimed
that apple was developing their own
gaming controller not only that but
leakers like fudge were also talking
about the new controller being meant for
gaming not just for an apple tv but then
it started to get very interesting when
fudge mentioned that apple arcade was
getting big money poured into it with
titles in the works that are aiming to
rival the likes of zelda breath of the
wild but wait it gets even better
because there was a very interesting and
convincing leak out of hong kong with
apple apparently working on a new
portable hybrid console like the
nintendo switch which basically saved
nintendo with its huge success but even
better apple was apparently preparing a
new chip with a new model name not the
apple a series or the m series featuring
a bigger focus on gpu performance as
well as ray tracing support now what was
really interesting to me was the part
where apple was negotiating with ubisoft
among other famous gaming developers and
this isn't the only place where we saw
information like this in january of 2021
the verifier claimed that apple was
working on an expanded arcade plus
service with apple apparently working
with major and well-known gaming
companies in order to offer their games
on apple platforms this is hugely
important because the number one thing
that's holding apple back from being
huge in the triple a gaming space is the
actual games themselves since their
hardware is absolutely powerful enough
to support aaa games so if apple worked
with big gaming companies that would
finally make apple more aaa gaming
viable and if you're doubting the apple
would actually do this it makes total
sense because any investment apple makes
into the gaming space will be hugely
beneficial for their upcoming vr headset
that is expected to come next year so
they'll obviously need a huge library of
popular games ahead of the vr headset
launch but now let's get into all the
most recent leaks including the new
apple patents to prove to you guys that
the new apple gaming system is coming
apparently within the recent podcast
xbox 2 on youtube windows central writer
jess corden revealed that apple has been
poaching xbox engineers to make its own
gaming console and just to give you a
bit of evidence for this rumor apple
currently has a job opening for a game
center engineer manager up on their
website and the description talks about
building engaging developer and customer
experiences in the gaming space and then
moving forward we just got another huge
leak from taiwan discussing apple
finalizing plans to make its debut with
a dedicated gaming console which means
it could be coming sooner than we all
expected and just to imagine what this
could look like constantine melanine on
twitter made these awesome looking
renders of what apple's gaming console
could end up looking like and i think
it's beautiful but the big deal from the
taiwan leak was that both capcom and
ubisoft were in active talks with apple
among other leading game companies in
terms of exclusive games which is really
exciting and now with all those leaks
out of the way let's finally get into
the new apple patent filings that
confirm that apple is extremely
interested in gaming more than anyone
thought last month apple won a game
controller patent with emphasis on thumb
stick input which shows that they're
serious about gaming this time around
instead of just using digital controls
but it gets even better because apple
had another patent filing showing off a
variety of gaming controller styles like
one which literally mimics the nintendo
switch with removable grips on both
sides of an iphone which can attach to
it and not only that but you can play in
portrait mode as well as you can see in
this iphone image and even with an ipad
which i wasn't expecting at all and now
in the second style it looks sort of
like a stand where your iphone is
propped up but you also have a keyboard
and controls within a secondary display
below giving you extra information and
even a keyboard for chat and then the
last style looks more like a traditional
gaming controller which can of course be
used for gaming but also for answering
phone calls and responding to text
messages and emails but what really blew
my mind was the next set of apple
patents that show off a variety of game
controllers that magnetically attach to
an idevice like the iphone and include a
smart foldable carrying case and when it
says magnets i think it refers to using
apple's mag safe accessory system which
i think is very important to apple
because they're going to be putting mac
safe chargers into their future apple
car the first style features a foldable
gaming controller which attaches to your
iphone with mac safe and can flip up
with a hinge giving you extra controls
on the bottom while gaming and another
image shows the possibility of using the
dual displays for vr and ar gaming which
is an interesting concept but what i
think is by far the most likely is this
style where you place your iphone onto
the magnetic game controller and there
are joysticks or controls sticking out
of both sides and you can even use the
iphone or ipad in portrait mode for
games that only support that mode
instead of landscape and the beauty of
this one is that it perfectly combines
the max safe idea with the first patent
of a nintendo switch style gaming
controller and what this reminded me of
was the new game sir x3 iphone gaming
controller which golden reviewers showed
off on youtube which features controls
on both sides just like apple's patents
and even a built-in cooler on the back
but the secret about apple's max a
version of the controller is that they
will likely also be able to transfer
data through maxsafe instead of using
the lightning port which will be an
amazing new feature especially when the
portless iphone comes out in the future
so the big question to all of this is
this is apple's brand new gaming system
actually a new gaming console with a
brand new chip or is it just making a
mac safe gaming controller well for now
we can't really tell but i think we're
getting pretty close to a release of
apple's new leaked gaming system because
this year the iphone 14 lineup is
rumored to finally ditch the mini size
which means it'll be easier for a new
potential controller to support the
entire iphone lineup and as for the
original question in the title on
whether it's coming at wwdc or not i
think it's a bit less likely because it
might be too soon and we've already got
some new max rumor to come so i think
the new gaming releases will probably
wait until sometime in the fall but if
you completely disagree with me then
comment your thoughts down below but if
you enjoyed this video click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and definitely check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]